[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits a podcast where
two lifelong friends talk about life for
a long time I'm link and I'm red this
week at the round table of dim lighting
I'll be catching you The Listener and
you the link yep uh up on my Caribbean
vacations
spring break for Shepherd I went down
there to try to get close to our other
son so that he could join us for a
little bit uh had some Adventures I'm
gonna say that most of the stories that
I'm gonna tell apart from a few
catastrophic things that happened at the
very beginning of the trip I love
catastrophic uh it's gonna read a little
bit like a tourism ad for Grand Cayman
uh okay how to sponsor them not a
sponsor but highly recommended but not a
sponsor not a sponsor highly recommended
uh trigger warning I mean I'm gonna I'm
a privileged man talking about her
privileged guys vacation okay if that's
triggering
listen away to something else are you
going to mention trigger fish uh well
and Trigger warning there is something
uh I don't I'm not a huge fan of trigger
warnings because the the world the world
doesn't give you trigger warnings and we
all have to live in the world but you
know what this is a safe space this is
your biscuits
um trigger warning there's something I
think what you really meant by that was
the first trigger warning was a joke if
you're going to complain about me
talking about my vacation just don't
listen to this that's the first thing
and then the second one the second one
is an authentic trigger warning which is
something kind of shocking and
disturbing that involved something
getting hurt
um
really early in the vacation happened
and uh I'm I'm gonna tell the story and
it's a little bit funny but mostly
tragic but that's not it it's almost
completely tragic that's not specific
enough to
I know but if I tell you I'm not exactly
what it is that happened I I'm gonna
give it away too much if I tell you
exactly if I give you the TR why you
should be triggered okay I'm fine with
that so it's just a general thing I do
have a question yeah
um I just couldn't help but notice that
as you were talking to me I could see
your eyes go down to my like mouth or my
chin is there something here that's
distracting you because do I need to
remove something from my face oh oh it's
on your mic it's not your face it's not
there's just something on your mic I
didn't think it could be seen so well I
wasn't looking at your face I was
looking at your mic okay but I saw that
like that's very disturbing it was funny
and when you said that I was like I
haven't looked at his mouth in years
I'm looking at your mic it had a hair on
it
I don't believe it was one of yours
probably somebody else we share these uh
mics with lots of folks well I think it
might have been a dog hair
which could have been on my face huh
but before I give you that update nuzzle
before I leave but before I give you
that update uh you know you were left
stranded here in Los Angeles without me
I was thriving uh so
you got any updates
actually I do
um
I'll spare you having to listen I mean
you're not going to listen to my solo
podcast I didn't listen to yours right
totally of course of course not it's
totally fine yeah um we see each other
enough I uh well I'll put it to you this
way I didn't plan it but at the
beginning I kind of I don't know things
just kind of ramped up very quickly and
I kind of went gangbusters
yeah me can you believe you went
gangbang I went into this mode tangents
that had tangents that had tangents and
I just couldn't I couldn't stick with it
and I think
you know at one point I said you know
what I'm not I was when I later when I
was talking about my anxiety I was like
you know what I don't I think that's
when I said it I'm not I wasn't nervous
at all about doing the podcast on my own
I would typically be very apprehensive
about it but I think subconsciously I
was like oh I better fill every second
and there was something subconscious
going that like the first 25 minutes of
the podcast was talking about 18 things
at once and part of it was
a bit of a performance experiment you
know what if I went to more of like a
impassioned yelly voice isn't that what
solo podcasters are supposed to do I
don't know do you listen to any
podcasters no and um
the other thing was that I guess because
I couldn't interrupt you or be
interrupted by you it could happen
um no comment I just thought I would
interrupt myself
again and again and again and I think
that was kind of part of it sounds like
a pleasure I hate I missed it it was
kind of part of the bit in my mind I
think was like you know nobody's here
for me to interrupt what if I just kept
interrupting myself
that could be funny yeah that's that
sounds cool matter of fact I think I
remember saying on the podcast at the 25
minute Mark or so
I was like you know what I'm not I'm not
gonna use my entertainer voice anymore I
was using some voice now I'm going to go
back to being my normal you use an
entertainer voice that's what I called
it maybe I could have listened to this
I've seen some feedback that people you
know people had fun it was like
what's going on here
but I'm here for it it's what some
people said but yeah then I was like all
right let's let's settle down let's get
into some
uh some realer
I would go into more uh my actual real
mode okay kind of like what I'm doing
right now this is real mode this is real
mode homie all right so one of the
things that I did want to clear up I
there was one question about my like how
I deal with anxiety and I ended up
sharing about how I decided to go off my
anxiety medication
and as I felt and I gave all the reasons
you know the reasons because I've told
you
um
so you don't have to listen to that
and
I basically presented it as I'm seeing
it which is this is an information
gathering exercise it's not I'm not I'm
not trying to
I'm not saying anything negative about
being on anxiety medication or positive
about getting off of it like it was it
was just
an experiment an experiment of do I
do I still need this as as a part of my
anxiety regimen along with the other you
know the other things the
um therapy
um
talking and sharing and getting feedback
from trusted family and friends
and things of that nature and I just
want to go ahead and give you an update
I'm back on the medication
like it was it's a little weird because
like I think the way I presented it was
and this is going this is going well
and I don't know if I don't know if
that's exactly I think that's how I came
across and that's what I was thinking at
the time of recording that podcast now
I'd been off of the medication since
when did we go on that Couple's Retreat
because I remember it was kind of around
that time was that
February early February yeah early
February so I know I was going off of it
about that same time or I was about to
um so it's been a couple of months
and
I just started observing that
I've been really on edge
that I've been really
having a difficult time not being
reactive
you know and part of it is okay well is
it me just going off the medication is
this a transition period And this is
some of the symptoms of that
but
um because it had been a little bit
longer
and
I just felt like there was this it
wasn't like the heart palpitations
didn't come back like that was the thing
I talked about as being a definitive
thing that like that would be an obvious
reason for me to go back on the anxiety
medication because I it definitely
helped with that and that was
uh easy to measure
but short of that like being more
attentive to how my brain is working and
how I'm interacting with people and just
having a short fuse and
even throwing a few Tantrums
you know uh
getting mad and kicking stuff
punching a thing like this is not
this is not something that I want to be
a part of my life right yeah and I'm
like why
okay I'm gathering this information but
do I
am I playing into this Trope of like
uh well I'm doing so much better now I
don't need the medication but it's
really the medication that's making me
better right very very common very
common I think I had to I had to find
out for myself and I have and I was like
you know what there's I don't experience
side effects of taking uh Sertraline
slash Zoloft
so for me what would be the reason to
not be on it if I've been experiencing
the benefits and now I actually know
that I'm missing those benefits
and I think honestly there's
um
there was there's still this element of
I guess shame is the right word of like
oh you're taking a medication every day
for your to balance your mood or to help
with your anxiety it just seems like I
don't know there's something there is a
voice there that's like
yeah if you were this if you were just
better in this way then you wouldn't
need this
so I mean there's a cultural that's what
there's
there's a stigma associated with any any
mental health aid exactly it's just like
you know if your knee wasn't if your
knee was built a little bit differently
and you weren't having this issue with
it you wouldn't need to wear this brace
every day it's like
um you know no one no one in their right
mind would say that to somebody or you
should say that to themselves shout out
to the knee issue people oh
um I'm one of those and
the other part of going off of it the
main part I thought was the Curiosity of
it but I just had to be honest and say
there's still a bit of stigma that is
still deep within there that little
voice and you know what I'm not gonna
listen to it
so I've only been back
on it for like five days now
and I am surprised
at
it's I won't say it's a night and day
difference but I am surprised with how
much I notice
the difference a positive impact
just my level of positivity and my
ability to whether
crinkles you know life crinkles right
you know I would I just I would fixate
on these things I would sink my teeth
into it and then if it if there were
like three crinkles in a row in my day
you know something happens in traffic
then you say something that I take
sideways when I get into work and then I
feel like I didn't do a good job when I
was recording a podcast or doing
something well then it's like three
strikes I'm out and then I just felt
like
I was I could
I couldn't get over the hump anymore
like I couldn't get in a place where I
could
um
engage with my life in a positive way
and I think that
it was because it's so subtle it's easy
to write off and to minimize but
I just want to I just want to
acknowledge it you know I think because
I do think it's a common experience to
go through and uh yeah you if you've
been on something for a while and you
feel like it's hard to measure
you're like well is this working I
actually feel very confirmed in in being
on the medication
uh as a result of this
uh
experiment information finding Excursion
and um so yeah I thought I thought it
was important that I like tie a bow on
that because it's just so funny that
it's like it happened so quickly in the
podcast it was like it almost feels like
oh I'm doing this and then I changed my
mind but the timeline was such that it
had been a while it was more more time
had passed than the podcast schedule
indicates yeah so
uh well welcome back anxiety mid
for the win welcome back this win
um yeah I mean you you know you because
you talked to Jesse a little bit about
this I mean she because she's had
experience you know both trying to
experiment early on in her life I mean
she's been on SSR ssris for 20 years but
um
earlier like she she got off on got off
of them for both pregnancies
and uh and then like six months after
the pregnancy so she was like a little
double whammy of like postpartum
depression and also being off of her
meds and she's you know it's made a huge
difference for her so
she you know like she told she told you
this I was talking to her I was I was I
wanted to talk to her
because I I was like I'm thinking about
doing this I'm actually planning on
doing it
what's your input and like she didn't
have to say anything like she had this
look on her face it was like I'm gonna
be supportive and it'll be positive but
uh no my own experience dictates you
have to find out for yourself I mean
it's not like something that and again
you're also not saying that if you're on
an SSS SSRI that
you should be or have to be on them
forever as a blanket statement because
they're it's everybody's different
everybody's everybody responds to them
differently so yeah
um okay let's talk so there we go isn't
that good yeah that was great it's great
man wasn't that good you haven't snapped
at me at all today
did you I mean
had you noticed
um
I would say here I here I'm going again
with some feedback let's just keep this
short no no I I you talked about that
one moment where you punched that thing
um well we're filming the Rhett and Link
channel and video another video that has
a uh
a portable radio I do remember showing
up and seeing you sit sitting there
because the you'll see we'll talk about
the video but the whole point of the
video is that we're apart and then we're
together and when I like showed up
there was a look on your face that I was
like he's not in a great place right now
yeah he's not happy right now and I can
imagine that he might get mad at
somebody or me
if I had it sideways and then you took
it out on them you remember I had a
smile on my face at that moment
um I was really thinking
I'm gonna put a smile on my face well
you know what that helps sometimes I
know I was trying like literally that's
what I was doing but you saw through
that and then uh if you're a member of
the mythical Society there's a uh Nick
shot a piece with just me
before you got there that's that's going
to be on the mythical Society oh and um
yeah I was uh
I was not at my best
did you check it out on Nick a little
bit but I I think I was just like uh I I
mean you can watch that video through
the through the lens of me just being at
which it was a very it was a very
demanding day it was I was frazzled when
I showed up for reasons that you'll
understand when when you see the video
um and I guess I should go ahead and
plug the mythical Society since we're
here yeah um
Michelle
was murdered uh on Good Mythical Morning
right there in front of all of our eyes
um she actually exploded into fabric it
was gross
um and um we are committed
to finding the killer what you know what
the killer has been found yes uh but
you've got to be a first second or third
degree member of the mythical Society to
see the complete documentary of the
investigation featuring True Crime
featuring lots of uh a special
investigator named Vinnie yeah yeah who
may or may not be played by Jordan so if
you're uh if you're a fan of
Jordan
the real person behind cotton candy
Randy he is um he's the star of this
investigation and he is not the Killer
it's a true crime documentary are you uh
about a fictitious character that we
Maui someone guilt
mythicalsociety.com that's what you get
with a society
ear biscuits is brought to you by
betterhelp of course I hope you know
we're huge fans of therapy and for me
therapy is me time you know it's a time
where I can say this is about me
processing my life gaining a deeper
understanding of myself and if it wasn't
a scheduled part of my in my case every
week then
um I may not I may severely neglect that
exercise so it's an important part of my
life yeah and it can be an important
part of yours too it can be hard to do
things just for you but therapy can help
you find that balance in your life and
that's why we like better help because
it makes therapy accessible through the
internet there's so much flexibility to
it I mean again for me
I don't having a standing appointment is
so beneficial because there's so I just
don't know what what's going to hit me
in my life
and then I just know that okay I have
this place where I can process it
get things out work through things get
things out and just kind of instead of
letting them Fester yeah if you're
thinking of starting therapy give better
help a try it's entirely online designed
to be convenient flexible and suited to
your schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and you can switch
therapists anytime for no additional
charge find more balance with better
help visit betterhelp.com ear today to
get 10 off your first month that's
better
h-e-l-p.com slash ear
earbiscus is supported by chime good
money habits start with your first
paycheck and if you're someone who just
got your first job well you can start a
healthy Financial Journey
Congratulations by the way uh when you
sign up for chime and Link a qualifying
direct deposit you get access to
benefits like getting paid up to two
days early and fee free overdraft up to
200 and with chime there are no monthly
fees no minimum balance and no deposit
required to become a member so sign up
for a chime checking account today to
link your paycheck it only takes two
minutes and it does not affect your
credit score get started at chime.com
ear that's chime.com ear chime is a
financial technology company not a bank
banking services and debit card provided
by The Bancorp Bank n a or stride Bank n
a members FDIC Early Access to direct
deposit funds depends on payer spot me
eligibility requirements and overdraft
limit Supply seechime.com spot me
okay
uh we planned on going to the Caribbean
uh for two reasons number one
we had gotten um scuba certified you
know and I wanted to be able to go to a
great location for that Caribbean is
known to be that Grand Cayman is also
known to be that in particular
and it was a short flight from Miami
where Locke is currently residing and
while it was not coincidental to his
spring break
he doesn't have class on Friday so he
could fly down on Thursday and be with
us Thursday through Sunday so basically
the last four days or so gotcha so that
was the plan and that plan was executed
okay there you go but the first
half of the week or a little bit more
than half of a week was just me and
Jesse and Shepard
um and you know how when you go to a
location where there's uh not a Jet
Bridge
when you get off the plane it just steps
it's just steps it's just steps into
humidity that's a good sign right it's a
great sign it's a great feeling
especially hold on that's what happens
at Burbank uh well Burbank I love that
about Burbank do you love a good Burbank
it doesn't always happen at Burbank does
it no it always happens I don't fly
enough there's never been for six or
seven years probably there's never
there's not one tube it's just steps um
it's great it's a great feeling you feel
like a little bit cooler
because when you see people like getting
off of like private jets which I've
never been on before near their steps
there's no Jet Bridge
but also Friday I'm just going to tell
you it's well you're not really going I
mean it's not I mean okay
but uh
it's been so cold I I've been so looking
forward now you might be like it hasn't
been cold I'm from Minnesota okay well
I'm not I live in California I've lived
in California for 12 years I've
completely adjusted and it's been rainy
and unusually cold every morning we wake
up
even this morning it was 45 degrees when
I woke up but every single morning
it's in the 30s or 40s for months on end
and that's just not why anybody lives
out here okay there's a lot of things we
tolerate out here like massive traffic
air pollution so many people
Etc incredibly high prices for living
here but one of the reasons we tolerate
all that entitled rich people is for the
weather for the weather the weather has
sucked
everybody's leaving
also you're only as good as your
accomplishments
well uh yeah that that's a vibe that we
that we often get around here but I
looked at the weather in Grand Cayman
and it was going to be a high of 82 and
a low of 78 the entire time that we were
there
a four degree window it's a tight window
a four degree window and listen that's
my temp I like it a little toasty you
know 72 and sunny that's La when it's
perfect and that is great but for me 80
degrees man 80 degrees is is a gr it's a
great temperature especially when the
Sun goes down if it's 79
76 guy I don't know I love it I love
just a sweating just a little bit
sweating just a little bit 74 and sunny
I like it when you feel like you got to
be naked to to get to the right
temperature
okay okay so we get off of the the plane
and of course this is how they do in
Caribbean places at airports there's
like a guy on a steel drum
outside of the airport the tarmac on the
tarmac under a tent playing as you get
there because again it's about the vibe
it's getting to the spirit of vacation
you're here to relax or you're here to
like shelter some money offshore at a
bank you know that's not why I was there
in Grand Cayman did you see people
Sheltering money no but it's known as
that it's a tax-free Haven a lot of
people bring it in suitcases uh I don't
think that's how it works it's probably
electronic transfers I would hope but
people have headquarters there
but anyway the get the Caribbean Vibe
going and um I'm feeling so good that I
and Jesse was like don't don't and I
begin I'm dancing I'm dancing off of the
off the plane I didn't and I didn't even
know I was doing I was so happy that it
was warm and that's when you fell no I
did not fall that's not when the tragedy
happened uh but I the one of the guys uh
one of the security guys pointed at me
and nodded he was like you know what's
up you know what I'm saying he he wasn't
he wasn't embarrassed for me he knew
what I knew what was up right I mean I'm
getting into the mood man I know what
you were there for and then of course I
have to like be in the Customs line for
almost an hour come on what do you think
I'm trying to do here I'm just here to
have a good time bring in C I'm not yeah
I'm not trying to plant foreign
vegetables you know or bring like a
little rabbit that's gonna take over
your whole island
I didn't think about that though if I
brought a couple of rabbits
you know like invasive rabbits uh-huh
you thought about that think about the
damage that I could do man
I'd probably go to jail for a long time
but I would hope so you could like make
an island be known for a specific
species of rabbit and be like you know
that's the rat McLaughlin rabbit
he took a chance one time he brought a
couple
onto the island he's in jail now yeah
but all these rabbits are named after
him I don't know it's just something to
think about
it's a big problem it's not anything
that I did though and then there's a
whole tourist industry around like come
to the island to kill the rats rabbit
hunting yeah all you want rabbits do all
day long
so get some Elmer Fudd action I'm in a
great mood I'm having a great time it's
difficult as I've established before on
this particular podcast it's difficult
for me to get into vacation mode because
the way my brain works and a lot of
times I see vacation as an opportunity
to just get all the other stuff done
like the mental work related to our work
the creativity right something whatever
plan something
but I'm kind of in a good place with
that right now and I feel
um
you know we're prioritizing our Cree
it's we're trying to prioritize our
creative time and our Creative Energy
and that kind of thing so I felt less
pressure to be like I got to come back
from this vacation with seven great
ideas which is typically how I do so
just so you know I didn't have any ideas
on vacation uh I'm glad it was about me
having a good time and connecting with
my family good and uh
uh we're feeling great as we get into
the taxi to go to the resort now Grand
Cayman is a small island there's about
this is something that I do when I get
on an island as I immediately go to the
wiki entry and I start getting facts
kind of like the old guy in front of me
at the John Mayer concert I wouldn't do
that at a concert I freaking look down I
wouldn't do that I always got blasted in
the face by like the brightest light
ever during the first song
of his show and it's a guy seated
checking his email he should be escorted
out
I called him the f word to Christy with
an ER on the end I was like if this F
worder
doesn't shape up but you didn't call it
to his face I'm gonna have to say
something to him and then in the next
song I get blasted in the face again
with a bright light and I look down
over his shoulder
second song of the freaking concert
he's on John Mayer's wikipedia page
reading
like getting up to speed well check my
email and I'm gonna figure out who who's
who is this guy who is this guy that I'm
I'm at his concert don't drag me into
this because that's not what I was doing
okay I wasn't in a John Mayer concert
that was I'm getting in I'm in a taxi
I'm on the way to the resort and I
hadn't and I usually do this let me get
some facts before I before I get there
because I'm fascinated by Islands not
just because you can overpopulate them
with foreign rabbits but because of the
isolation and the history and just the
fact that it is an island weird stuff
happens on Islands you know weird
evolutionary things happen and then
there's also cultural Evolution but then
there's these this specific history of
every Island
and I was like okay what's the deal with
Grand Cayman you know that's what I said
it just like that in my brain and I
looked it up and there's like 75 000
people who live there uh it does not
have any there there are no native
people that were ever there as far as
they know okay meaning the first people
showed up as tourists uh in like the
I don't know so I can't remember if it
was a 1600s or the 1700s but like pretty
late pretty late okay
um and it was a bit of like a ragtag
group of people it was like kind of a
lawless society and there was a bunch of
different people that were there for all
kinds of different reasons and all their
descendants or many of their descendants
still live there and that's the people
of Grand Cayman it's pretty interesting
but also it's it's part of the
Commonwealth so it's the queen is on the
money
and um there's a lot of British people
there there's a lot of Indian people
there as well because it was you know
part of the Commonwealth back in the day
and okay anyway
so I'm kind of like I'm I'm asking
questions to the cab driver and I'm like
are you from here like did you did you
grow up here like what's it like like
oh wow and we are
three minutes into the ride okay this is
where the trigger warning comes in yeah
and we're 30 minutes in this box okay
we're three minutes into make a note of
that but let me just say you know what
just see if you can get through it I I
just I just invite you to get through
this story
I'm nervous
and uh
we're going we're on the road and there
is there's a bunch of taxis on and there
are all these sort of big Vans right
everybody kind of the taxis are all just
Vans for how it doesn't matter how many
people are in your party you're gonna
get into a van
and there's a van in front of us which
is another taxi and we're kind of just
like looking around the island and then
we see a cat come out into the road no
in front of the van and like I'm in a
great mood I'm having a great time we're
all laughing and we see this cat get
absolutely demolished by this van in
front of us
Okay and like we have like
a few seconds of watching the last
moments of this cat's life right and it
is just Soul crushing it is it takes all
the air out of the van it completely
stops the conversation you gave a
trigger warning be more specific
everybody what was he doing what was the
cat doing well
remember that time yeah don't don't talk
about it that you hit accidentally hit
that animal yeah and then we sat there
and watched it die yeah it was like that
except we were able to drive past it as
opposed to just sit there and watch it
we didn't have to be told to leave oh my
God
was awful and I'm not you know as you
can imagine I'm not particularly
sensitive to this kind of thing on the
spectrum of people right I'm not saying
there's nothing about it that I enjoy I
don't like cats but I do not like any
animal to experience any discomfort
uh but for for Jesse this was this was
like it's like it it it it risked
coloring the vacation
like significantly right because it was
just shocking and we just sat there in
silence
for like 10 minutes
as we got to the hotel and I was like
damn it
that was it
that's like what does that mean what was
Shepherds
Shepherd was like Shepherd he was in
shock but he also like he's like me and
so that he was thinking about the fact
that it's like it's so tragic it's
horrible I can't believe we saw that but
you kind of have to like be like isn't
it crazy that that just happened that we
got off of the freaking we're all
excited and this [__] cat gets killed
in front of us like it's you have to
kind of laugh just to kind of get
through it that's kind of where his his
brain works like mine right it's tragic
so like
uh so oh at that point I was like what
does this mean you know let's let's
redeem this and I decided that it meant
nothing oh I decided that it meant that
a cat
right got in front of a car yeah and got
killed and it's horrible but it happens
and I don't have anything to do with it
and it's not going to impact my vacation
it wasn't your car and then when I
showed up at the hotel and I heard some
more steel drums I forgot all about that
damn cat
I forgot all about the cat well it
wasn't your cat it wasn't my cat I don't
you know honestly I don't think it was
anybody's cat I think it was the
Island's cat you know what I'm saying
there's many of them including there's
also lots of chickens that roam free
kind of like Kauai
so anyway I believe that was his ninth
life just based on the the situation
with both of the wheels it was his
eighth and Ninth life oh my God and it
was horrible but
it did not it threatened to uh to ruin
the vibe but it didn't I was able to get
the Vibe back once we got to the hotel
this could that could be your new cold
shower image though
Oh you mean when you're trying not to
ejaculate
that's that's Redemptive right there I
just think about Richard Nixon use it
for your own sexual performance I'm not
a crook that's what I think about when
I'm trying not to ejaculate
I he gets me soft so fast
[Laughter]
so anyway
if if that starts to change
that's the risk that is the risk that's
a big risk I'm open I'm fluid man if all
of a sudden I'm attracted to Richard
Nixon I'll do something about it
um what
don't answer that
so my the thing that I was most excited
about was the scuba diving of course and
I you're welcome was
and it's funny how having something
planned on a vacation
I mean first of all
having something planned on a vacation
is one of the ways that I feel secure
because of
things about my personality like
having reservations at good restaurants
important to me having the activities
planned important to me I'm very much
like Stevie in this regard Stevie is
even better at this than I am in terms
of like if Stevie's going on a trip with
us
she takes full charge of what everything
that we're gonna do I it's great you
know just the restaurant this restaurant
um but I'm that person in my family I'm
the planner
because I'm in a family of non-planners
and I'm not much of a planner it's a
burden in general but no I kind of enjoy
it I I kind of enjoy it because I'm like
oh guys on Thursday night we're going to
the highest rated restaurant on the
island you know and I and I I attach the
rabbit is succulent anticipate I
anticipate those things
it just makes you feel like okay well if
all else fails we've got these things
that we're gonna do and we will have had
a good time it's a little dadish I
realize that
but I was thinking about you are a dad
the yeah I am a dad I'm just fulfilling
the role I was thinking about these two
scuba diving trips so Tuesday and
Thursday Shepherd we're not and I were
gonna go on two Dives nice and as I told
you in a previous podcast I was very
excited about the Shipwreck dive right
yeah
but we go up to the place which was
literally attached to the hotel the
place where you write register okay it
was so convenient
um
the the the scuba diving place in like
water sports place
just checking in we want to get fitted
for you know our shorties or short
wetsuits or whatever you know the stuff
that you your fins mask
and
they're like how old is how old is that
one Shepherd
and I was like 14 years like well
unfortunately
he cannot go on the Shipwreck dive
because it's too deep as a as an Open
Water certified scuba diver age 14 60
feet is the maximum depth and you need
and you gotta this is a 65 foot deep 17
you could go
15. he can go it it there's a gradation
okay as you get older you can go deeper
I don't know exactly what that is I need
to look into that but they're like it's
14 you can't do this
so I was immediately like oh man that
first the cat and now
this this complication but I was also
like you know what we're gonna have a
great time like we all we've all we dove
in was California water which was cold
and wasn't that clear like we're in warm
water 170 feet of visibility 107 oh wow
it's like in being an heir
um
so I was a little disappointed now uh
the guy checking Us in eventually is
like why do you look so familiar
and uh I was like I don't ever like to
be presumptuous but I was like do you
watch a lot of Internet videos he was
like oh yeah the guys at the the desk
the guys the guys who eat
and uh turns out a lot of mythical
beasts
full-time residents of uh Grand Cayman a
lot of mythical beasts we have
infiltrated the island link nice and uh
I'm not saying that's why the next thing
that happened happened oh but he did
call me later that day and say hey you
know what I think we can we can we can
do the Shipwreck dive it's just that uh
Shepherd is not going to be able to go
into the bottom of the ship
he can go into the top of the ship oh
okay so we'll have to like make some
adjustments or whatever
but that was the Thursday Dive Right
that was the Thursday dive uh so I'm I'm
gonna show you some video this is going
to get very Visual and interactive uh
for those of you uh just listening this
is why you might skip over to YouTube I
want to go to YouTube and watch your
biscuits Channel but I took this uh
now don't get too don't get too excited
I mean this is my first time this is one
of my first this is my first time
like recreational diving past my
training and I'm also trying to be a
diving cinematographer with a camera
that I just bought
but the way this thing works is it's a
360 camera
inside of a dive case
uh so it because it's in the dive case
like it's you're gonna see there's this
thing on the screen where it's like the
bottom of the camera and then I had to
put it through software where I select
the 16x9 frame that I actually want to
display on my computer so that it kind
of will be making some choices you don't
have to point the camera at the time you
just you decide what you want to so to
speak pointed at yeah in the first dive
I just left the camera on the whole time
I learned my lesson that's too much
footage it's like 45 minutes of footage
so I did you know I did do the work so
I'll just show you you know I'm gonna
I'm gonna start you know the first dive
was just a reef dive right okay so um
you know there's nothing nothing too
special here this is just a moment in
which we encountered a turtle
uh as you can see that what is that
thing that's I've got the thing floating
so this is the this is it's on a thing
it's just on a tether floating right oh
so that's the bottom of the case and so
I just want I started the video like
this to show you now I said oh I'm gonna
grab this thing and here's this turtle
uh that you can see right there
everybody's like there's a freaking
turtle and of course this is like let's
surrounded that we're diving with
um and then in the software you can
actually track the turtle so you can
just make the turtle be the center of
the screen and then as long as the
turtle is there it'll just keep it'll
keep track of them I don't know exactly
what that was that where it zoomed in
for a second because I don't quite
understand the software yet but this was
pretty much the most exciting thing no
Shepherd is here uh no Shepherd is over
to my right
you might see him
in a second so not much to see there you
can kind of see oh it's pretty it's
pretty clear it's beautiful but this was
just kind of like adjusting and getting
and getting into the groove right then
we uh the guy was like we're actually
for our second dive we're gonna go to a
shipwreck already we're gonna go to a
shipwreck and so this shipwreck that
you're about to see uh
I can't remember you know honestly I
can't remember the name of it right now
I wrote it down somewhere it's in my
dive log on my on my my dive computer
um but this is a shipwreck that has
completely disintegrated
uh and I'm gonna basically so there's
like pieces on the bottom the whole
thing is just disintegrated this is the
uncut video so I'll just kind of scrub
through there's the engine right there
there's Shepard having a great time not
to touch the stuff uh it did it
basically the guy was just like just
watch yourself but then you can see the
stern of the boat over here look the
stern of the boat they're shover the
stern of the boat is is over here by
itself this is pretty cool so one of the
things that was this do you know uh
I think it was just like a fishing boat
or whatever as you can see like we're
going up here to the little holes in the
boat see I'm just kind of teasing you a
little bit here like this is what it
looks like to be on the outside of a
shipwreck that's cool um but you can see
what how the camera adjusts once we put
it in through this hole like how it like
adjusted the light and you can actually
see you'll see in a second as it adjusts
and like we're inside of a boat there
now you can't go inside this right
uh but over here outside of the boat
there are these bicycles
bison bicycles on the floor of the ocean
and the guy said that the reason there's
bicycles on the floor of the ocean is
that there was a time in which people
who were divers or dive instructors on
the island would be leaving
and they would ride they had their they
had their bikes that they had been using
to get around and they're diving
equipment and stuff and they would like
right they would throw their bikes and
stuff off of a ship as they were leaving
because they didn't need it anymore well
that sucks and so they're just on the
floor of the ocean okay so so that's
basically day one was like seeing that
reef and then seeing the ship and we
like we get back and we're like I'm
happy that you know there was no like
there was no real complications we had a
great time I'm like I'm looking at the
footage in the hotel I'm like yeah I got
some good footage I could show that on
the podcast feeling good feeling good
and I've gotten the call about going but
we can actually go on the Shipwreck and
then another cat we know we show up on
Thursday and uh you know what I'll tell
you another uh there was something else
that happened that was a little bit
negative yeah good okay
and that was actually the the easy to
complain a little bit more about your
vacation the Monday before the first
dive I forgot about this but this was
another sign that maybe things could go
wrong so Shepard and I were just getting
started and we knew we were looking
forward to the scuba diving but there's
all the like the water sports right
there on the on on the beach right and
I'm like yeah if all this stuff is free
you can just like you can paddle board
you can snorkel right here out next to
the resort and uh he's like Dad I want a
jet ski oh can I jet ski can we jet ski
and I was like well jet ski tomorrow
because I think this is actually Sunday
so I was like yeah well Jesse tomorrow
hey like we're just getting like hey
just calm down a little bit
I was like let's go snorkel at this spot
that these people have told us is like a
10 minute walk down that where it was
more of a reef
and so first of all like there's a
little bit of like teen upset coming
from Shepard about not getting a jet ski
today you know and I was like dude come
on don't be an ass like you don't have
to jet ski right now or let's have a
good time
and uh and so then we're walking and
about I don't know a minute into the
walk my knee really starts bothering oh
your knee you're a knee person uh I've
got bad knees in general tall guy stuff
but we're braces the left knee
my right knee is the one that I hurt
multiple times and also like screwed up
while skiing and has tendonitis but my
left knee hasn't been bad but then when
I was scuba diving training
uh and I tried to get out of the water
on those steps in Catalina and realize
holy [__] this stuff is heavy yeah I put
all my weight on that one leg and was
kind of in The Squatty position and like
my knees started hurting and it's been a
little bit it's not bad it's just been a
little bit off but you know when you're
walking on the beach and it's uh kind of
sloped and you're walking uneven and
it's like it's sand it's like hard but
soft and yeah it's a beach I've been on
it and it's just like something about
that exacerbated by my knee and so then
I'm starting to get a little upset and
I'm also a little upset because
Shepherd's a little upset with me for us
having to walk to this thing
instead of jet skiing right now okay and
I'm like my knees hurting
we got to get to this thing and then I'm
like I don't even know where this thing
is they said McLaughlin's they said it
was the governor's Beach where the thing
was it's like where's the governor's
thing and he's like I think it's right
up here I was like listen let's just
turn around and take a cab so we now we
walk back when he's hurting and we get
into a cab and the cab drives us
basically like 20 feet from where we
ended up turning around
we snorkel there and it was cool uh but
then we start walking I'm like we can
walk back my knee hurts but it'll be
fine 20 minute 20 feet cab ride yeah we
get back to uh the beach where Jesse's
hanging out and at that point I realized
because I had been carrying my
flip-flops and my camera and my snorkel
and my mask
and a bag
that somewhere along the way I dropped
my flip one of my flip-flops
lost a flip-flop and then I was like am
I gonna really go back with this bum
knee and try to find this flip-flop or
do I need flip-flops really
I've got some other I've got some other
like slip-on things all right so I lost
a flip-flop so there was the dead cat
and then a lost flip-flop I was like I
don't know man this is really it could
be a room I've had but the main thing
that was a problem was
the tension that it was causing between
me and Shepard early on right which is
not unusual to have tension with your
teenage child
uh but to be in a place where you this
is a it is a total privilege you should
that we are able to afford to be at this
place to afford to be able to take this
time off to do these things and I can
recognize that as an adult it's
difficult for a kid to recognize that
right they can can they can understand
the concept but that doesn't mean that
once you're there you really don't want
it you just want a jet ski so we ended
up jet skiing that day I was that Dad
that was like you know what I said hey
let's start over there's no reason for
us to be mad at each other let's go jet
skiing of course he had to be on the
back because he's for being 14 sucks oh
yeah you know because it's like you're
almost able to do all the stuff that you
want to do and you're capable of doing
all the stuff that you want to do but
you just can't so you guys are like hold
on to your dad's back while he's jet
skiing and keep yelling at him to go
faster
like the whole time he's in my ear he's
like Dad go full speed then take a hard
turn like he would throw me off like he
just constantly wants to be thrown off
of the jet ski and I'm like getting more
aggressive and more aggressive
and that those things will turn on a
dime they will but the thing is it will
throw you they turn so fast that it puts
so many G's on me and I've got this guy
holding on to me that like I'm I'm just
thinking about my own self-preservation
and not hurting my back like I'm like
you know like I'm just thinking about
I'm preoccupied being a dad's hard being
a middle-aged dad is hard you got a
teenager hold on to your back you're
trying not to get hurt you're trying to
almost throw him off so he'll be
satisfied but not throw him off
and you got one flip-flop one flip-flop
lost Barefoot at the time
anyway
um I think that was actually the jet ski
ride is when the things really turned
and I was like here we we are enjoying
this is about enjoying ourselves let's
just do it and Shepard and I got to a
good place now that was kind of undone
once lock showed up which I'll get to in
a second
um
the next thing that we did uh so this
was the this is pretty fascinating this
is the they call it the X USS Kitty wake
because when it's no longer in you know
X being used it's technically X so this
is a military ship not like a giant
I think it's like 200 feet long it's
pretty damn big you'll see
uh but this thing was purposely sunk
in like 2011.
because
Grand Cayman was already a diving
destination but it didn't have any big
shipwrecks like some of the other places
around the Caribbean okay and this is
the one that they that you Shepard got
like he slid in yeah so they they ended
up bringing this thing in back in the
day and they cut uh holes in the hole
uh and then they remove things like
wires and sharp things because they were
like this is going to be a coral reef
dive site
and so we're gonna make it enjoyable and
easy to navigate and not dangerous and
we're gonna sync it in about 40 feet of
water oh so that everyone can dive well
then a hurricane came along
a few years back
shifted the whole thing around sent it
further out and so that's why it's on
its side now and it's deeper and that's
why but you can kind of see uh I'll show
you this is just what it looks like
coming up to it
[Music]
so this is a big boat
that's the front of it of course
oh it's kind of on its side but not yeah
we're looking at the bowel is that the
bow is the bow is the front the nose the
front I think they call the bowel the
stars that is their Shep right there
uh and you can see
the see that hole
this is where and Shepard wasn't allowed
to go in there now the other thing that
happened on this dive is that when
Shepard got into the water
he realized that his BC his buoyancing
compensator you know that you're also a
dive guy
um he's inflatable was was leaking
oh and they made him come so he wasted
probably like 500 PSI dealing with this
thing now kids typically use a use their
air very quickly because they breathe
fast and they're darting all around so
it ended up being the case that the guy
and then of course you're doing your
thing where you're telling people how
much air you've got we were at the end
where we were about to go into the thing
and basically Shepard was down to like
so we had to go but I was like all right
we gotta go but I'm going to uh
I can't be I can't do this so I told
Shepard I was like hold on one second
and I was like I gotta go into this
thing so I did this so you went through
the hole Yeah the whole
yeah so you'll see once it adjusts here
the light
oh man that's cool so you can see they
just cut it's just like you could go
down that you can go through like it I I
want to go back because there's like
four levels
I thought you at a certain point you got
to get a special certification to do not
in this not for some reason not on this
one I don't understand why
oh man and then look there's like the
the top of the boat there's actually I
was like
either anymore I'm gonna go through here
huh I would love to do this because this
is reminiscent of
all of our exploring in the woods and
you'd like find a house or an abandoned
barn or silo or something and then
you're kind of
you just kind of exploring I love the
idea
the practice of exploring abandoned
things and to be able to like fly
through it
it's like flying the great thing about
it I have not done any type of wreck so
so I've been you know you know where
some of the best wrecks are in North
Carolina caves but this is a great one
because of how big it is and it's like I
definitely want to go back where Shepard
can go from the bottom and we're like
more relaxed uh but so we then we come
up you know have our hour on the surface
and then because you know you have to
have your interval period so that you
don't get the bins and then we went back
to uh the doc pawson another shipwreck
he was like it's a two shipwreck day and
this is the one
that we were able to go inside this is a
smaller shipwreck
um and of course so there's coral and
stuff growing all over this so it
becomes like a
a habitat
yeah so you can see this is a for real
shipwreck now it's smaller but it's
actually like
it was not planned this is just a ship
that sunk and it's still there so it's
got in this and it's falling apart quite
a bit and it's got stuff hanging all
over the place
was there were there any toilets stoves
or you think
I don't know the stuff that you have in
a ship like um I mean you can see what
they're Sailors nudie posters no I mean
this thing's been there forever
you know so then I want to show you the
coolest video
is this last one here of
um
once we're in there and so Shepard and I
basically I was like you're Shepard
coming out of that thing he's having the
time of his life
you know because it's just like it's so
women hard it's so cool
to be
yeah to access something I don't see any
other divers at this point where are
they I killed them all
uh no they're interesting see they're
outside there's for some reason me and
Shepard were always the last ones like
the first ones to go inside and the last
ones to leave I was like I don't
understand what the deal is it's like
I'm having such a great time in here
people get bored
uh it was also new to us you know but so
Shepherd goes through here and you'll
see this is a cool shot of me going
through and you kind of get the I've
shown this to a couple people who are
claustrophobic and they're they get a
little bit freaked out and I guess I'm
not claustrophobic because
it just I feel like I'm in something
that I shouldn't be I'm accessing
something that I shouldn't be able to
it's pretty tight oh it's it's like
you're in a crawl space it's getting
shorter and shorter here oh wow foreign
is it's almost like a buoyancy obstacle
course because you control it's not just
swimming up and down but you don't want
to swim to move up and down you want to
use your buoyancy control
you know and if you get good at that you
can
and it's actually your breath it's going
to save your breath or just use your
breath as buoyancy yeah so I I once I
get to a certain depth I'm just just
using my breath to go up and down very
slowly so anyway
that was it was incredible I mean we
gotta go we have to go to shipwreck man
we gotta I think there's shipwrecks that
we can go to in California
I totally want to do it
um you plan it I'll be there
yeah we gotta we gotta we gotta start
doing some like there's so many
locations around the world that have
these incredible sights man we gotta
like I mean I don't want it to be the
kind of thing Lincoln wants to he's he's
thinking about majoring in Psychology
going off to college in the fall
and I'm like
you should just you should be a scuba
uh dive guy around the world that's what
you should be you should be a Dive
Master or you should be a world traveler
have this conversation dive guy so that
then I call you up and I'm like hey
where you at now I'll meet you
it's some exotic location because it's
your job and I'm just coming to visit my
son that's not how Parenthood works
though they won't do what you ask them
to do because I said the same thing to
Shepard right so Shepherd you know what
you should do for a living scuba dive no
no I I just asked separate because we
got to know the the guy who was the
captain of our ship both days uh was an
Irish boy
um from the Homeland and he uh
oh it's just first of all he's very into
NBA basketball
like
so in he knew everything about every
team and every player like I was just
like that's strange I don't know how it
came up
I just said something he he you know he
asked me I guess if I play basketball
and I'm from America and I was like no
no but let's start talking about the
Clippers in the playoffs and then all of
a sudden
he gave me so much more than I needed oh
but one of the things I did get besides
all the sports information was the fact
that he had lived in Thailand as a dive
instructor for six years and then he had
been and came in for like five years
and this is what the dude does every day
I mean of course everything gets boring
and everything is up being in it right
you gotta shut up with these like but
he's doing he's leading the badge he's
going he's doing the diet every day
and I just had Shepard I was like
like would that be fun for you to like
at least for a little bit in your life
to like you know be like a dive
instructor and it's a location like this
and he was like
I don't think so
all right let's go jet skiing
um faster you wanna be a jet ski guy you
want to be a professional jet skier I'll
be a jet ski guy so
Thursday night lock shows up from Miami
okay and uh of course we're all happy to
be together as a family you know you you
cherish these moments of all four
McLaughlin's being in the same place
um
but it can be the case that
the family Dynamic uh that you
unintentionally established is
re-established sometimes when they're
all together
and in particular the dynamic between
Bros
so
there was a couple of barbs that were
thrown I mean first of it was great we
had a great time we went out to dinner
uh
you know because the sunsets are so
beautiful a lot so the restaurants are
like set up so that you can like eat and
watch this at the same time I mean it
was incredible right we're having a
great time yeah
but then I was like cat runs by Night
Swimming I gotta do Night Swimming ever
since we did Night Swimming in Miami all
those years ago for the nerd versus geek
shoot I've had this obsession with
trying to recapture the perfect night
swim that we had okay and the perfect
night swim can only happen in a place
that is warm oh yeah and the water is
warm of course
so and there's very little rules in this
hotel like you could go out to the beach
and swim around and there's no life
there's no lifeguards because it's kind
of like the way that the island is
situated in the Caribbean it's blocked
by all these other islands and so it's
like a lake there's I never saw a wave
the whole week really never a wave okay
and the tide only uh oscillates
like a very I don't know how tight I
know the tide is caused by Poseidon in
the in the sea uh but I don't know
exactly how it works
and I don't know why it's more in other
places like why it can be seven feet
some places it's like an a foot here I
don't know why you didn't read that far
in the Wikipedia no no I lost lost
interest but I was like there's these
platforms these inflatable inflatable
inflatable and by definition floatable
platforms
out in the ocean that people Lounge on
during the day I was like let's swim out
to one of those at night
and hang out on the platform oh yeah
so we go out there and uh was Jesse with
you no just me and the boys
and let the boys have their fun and so
we go out there and of course I'm trying
to get him to be scared of sharks like a
dad would do
nighttime sharks they feed at night time
you know and so that's freaking about a
little bit we get on the platform
and then uh Shepard just being you know
a little brother has the idea hey my big
bro is back in town
I'm gonna knock him off of the platform
you know it's just what brothers do
well a lot was not ready for this
Shepard pushes him off the platform Luck
get falls into the water he tries to get
back up he's trying to grab Shepard in
the process Shepherd ends up hitting him
in his face with his foot and then he
takes Shepherd throws him in the water
and I'm like hey guys break it up and so
we all kind of sit there for a second in
silence again it was another moment of
silence like for the kids
and I was like okay guys listen
and I was like lock Shepard was just you
know he's happy that you're here he's
trying to connect with you he's doing
what brothers do he's throwing you into
the water it's a love lick I've already
been in the water it's not like you were
in a ghetto and he's like but I think he
may have given me a concussion
when he kicked me and I was like I don't
think he gave you a concussion I think
everyone's going to be fine
but hey let's just say we all love each
other let's just get along so we sat
there after my speech
and I was like and sorry for yelling at
you but you were being [__]
uh and did you make him hug uh no we
just sat there for a little bit and then
we started talking about something else
and we got and we got over it uh so we
kind of corrected course
you know there's always you're adjusting
to a new environment that's right
but we gotta be nimble we had planned
some group activity the light crinkles
the last two group activities that I
will share uh we have planned for
Winlock was gonna be there and the first
thing was we were going to go to the
number one tourist attraction and all of
Grand Cayman and it's Stingray city of
course no it's better than Putt-Putt
Stingray City huh so this is a place
that again there's a history and it's
actually a relatively recent history
there's a place out on The Sandbar the
whole island is shaped like a giant sea
like the letter c probably more of a u
if you're thinking about North being at
the top
and
if you go to
kind of the top of the U it's where I
guess
thousands millions of years ago there
was probably it was probably just a full
island but now it's just a very shallow
Sandbar the U has you know the O became
a u and
there's these stingrays that
traditionally came out there because the
fishermen would be like cleaning their
fish after a day oh and the Stingrays
would come and eat and so they got very
friendly and familiar and then it turned
into essentially a tourist attraction
because it's very calm it wasn't that
calm the day we were there very shallow
and you're surrounded by stingrays the
size of this table what hundreds of them
show me the footage so I I don't the the
footage of this is was bad it was it was
like I just think it's you know what
I'll do I will Google Stingray City and
find a more compelling uh picture for
you and then take credit for that than
anything
um
so were you waiting in the water or were
you snorkeling or did you have to take a
boat out it's like this
it's like standing in this water and did
you walk off the beach to this no you
take a boat they take a Long Boat Ride
okay not a Long Boat Ride but you know
so like on our day there's about this
many people out there I mean we're
talking like a couple of hundred people
just like standing in knee-deep thigh
deep water and then like this guy one of
the guys who's with you
because they know how to hold them well
begin hugging one of them
and you can come up and you can stroke
it did you stroke it oh I stroked it
well he actually then he he basically
they're so like friendly and they're
just they're so used to people
and again I think it's a transactional
thing because they're like we get fed
yeah so we got to put up with these
people you know it's like they give us
the food and we let them play with us
uh he'll give it to you
and so you'll I I was holding it I was
holding one like that again Jesse had
the camera we she didn't really know how
to work it like I said it was there's
not good footage of this so it's not
even worth showing it to you but you can
imagine this picture of me being that
guy holding the stingray okay yeah uh it
was pretty it was pretty awesome I mean
getting to enter I felt a little bit
like
is this like swimming with dolphins is
this like are we exploiting these
animals and then the guy was like
each one of these stingrays based on the
amount of money that this particular
site brings in for tourism it has been
calculated that each one of these
stingrays is worth a million dollars
based on how many they are of them that
there are and how expensive the all the
trips because there's hundreds of people
paying
hundreds of dollars every single day
constantly to go out there I'm sure
there's people who don't like the idea
of this that didn't help but
um it is what it is
now
the next night basically the last night
so we did that like the next to last day
then the last night we did
um something called the bioluminescent
Bay oh so we're talking about night
glowing
what oh so I'll show you the pictures in
a second again
my camera is not sensitive enough to get
these photos so I've just got some you
know there's just you can Google these
photos as well
but basically this is a some rich dude a
long time ago in the 80s
dug out a lagoon on one part of the
island
and so it's like a man-made circular
Lagoon with all these really nice
properties around it
fresh water
no it's it's the it's the ocean it's
like
inside of a bay okay and then they
created a bay inside of this Bay gotcha
I'm sure it caused Great environmental
damage but it was done 40 years ago so
now the people who live around it
and
then the hurricane that came another
hurricane brought a bunch of sand into
it and created the perfect conditions
for it to be just shallow enough and
also isolated as this Lagoon kind of
it's it's it's connected to the beach
but like I don't know this this life
this bioluminescent these little
organisms
which the guy said what they were and
I'm sure you can look it up I can't
remember the name
there's like a million of them in a
cubic foot of water and they they don't
even really understand how it works or
what they understand how it works they
don't understand why when you agitate
them by moving your hand through the
water it lights up what oh my gosh so
and by the way so just it's like this is
all four of us it looks like
light dust yeah and see this right here
like where you like so you wear a you
wear a mask and you go under the boat
that the guy brings you out on because
it's even darker under there and you
like put your hand under the water and
you like you put your face under the
water so you can see it and you can like
see individual little things like if I
would just take my finger and just go
like this like really really move it and
it'd be like five six ten of these
little light things and you go and then
it was like they would explode into
light it was so crazy I was like and I
fell you were holding your breath like
such a great dad oh you did when
the boys kept saying this is the coolest
thing I've ever done
like they were just in this last night
there you go coolest thing they've ever
done
um and highly recommend that and then a
cat swim by and then we took no no cats
then we took a uh we took a taxi to get
the uh some jerk chicken at this like
barbecue stand on the side of the road
that was hard to find but it was like
you know everybody's like you got to get
the jerk chicken from this place we
wrapped up the evening did you so you
had the bioluminescent stuff on your
body
did you take a shower that's not how it
works man you don't know I'm sure there
was some of that stuff was just stuck to
you yeah but some of those beans just
like any but there's all kinds of stuff
in all kinds of water all the time I
know but did you shower I took very few
showers I took so that's a no uh I think
I took two showers in eight days because
it's the beach but I got Beach bod you
know what I'm saying that's not what
beach bot is
Beachbody is not a non-showered person
it was a matter of fact
um because of my long hair and
Shepherd's long hair when his hair is
even curlier than mine I like I I didn't
I didn't do any I did very little
hygiene because I was like in the salt
water in the sun it was it was wonderful
it's good for your skin I did a little
hygiene and uh nobody complained my wife
didn't complain I mean I wore deodorant
and I showered like at two intervals
throughout the throughout the thing are
you saying that if you go on a beach
vacation you shower every single day I
mean there's a lot of people gonna be
with me you come in off the beach man
yeah you're gonna shower off the sand oh
and the salt water I know I would um
I would uh get under the shower next to
the beach you were to get the salt water
off okay
um
but I wouldn't like be I want to go up
to the room and put soap on my body
right now I was like I don't I don't see
the point you know what I'm saying all
right except like twice when you went
through customs did you tell them about
the bioluminescent beans that were all
over your body because you had not no
they're they're prepared for that here's
the thing
is I
I noticed my hair was getting really
matted not matted but like you know oh
man boy when I get back home I'm really
gonna have to spend some time with my
hair it's like sometimes you just don't
want to take the time in the middle of
the vacation to take the 45 minutes that
it'll take to brush out your hair in the
shower like with the conditioner in it
and I was like I'm on vacation I'll just
let the knots continue to form and then
I'll just worry about it when I get home
and it ended up not being that big of a
deal
for Shepard whose hair is curlier than
mine who apparently had adopted the same
approach
he got home
and started to investigate his hair and
he basically was like you know dreading
up in certain places and
he said that he flipped a coin
and this is how 14 year olds make
decisions I guess he said if uh you know
heads I just wash my hair and get the
knots out Tails I cut my hair
okay and it was tails
he cut his own hair so Jesse got home
she sees
a bunch of hair in the trash can and
she's like I don't know if that's red
Sarah Shepherds here they're pretty
similar I guess time will tell and then
Shepherd came downstairs and she said
when he came downstairs he looked like
uh the way she described it was a 50
year old woman
um it was kind of like a bit just a big
globe of hair he had like cut the he had
cut the back and the sides but like left
the top and it was like very globish and
she's like oh gosh so she ended up
salvaging it and it looks good now I
think you saw a picture of it it looks
great I think it's an improvement I can
see his face most of the time
you know I appreciate being able to see
you don't want a team that just looks
like a cartoon character that has their
hair in their face the call time which
is what he had become and uh of course I
didn't say anything you can do whatever
he wants to do with this hair and he can
have the biggest possible genes that he
wants because that's that thing that's
happening now
but uh so yeah it was salvaged she's got
a little mini mullet kind of thing
happening so
uh all said
not a great start
but a great landing a great finish uh
lock was you know right before he got on
his plane back to Miami when we were at
the airport he he apologized to Shepard
he said I love you
I'm sorry for
kicking you
uh we all we had a big group hug
okay I think I gotta you know what I'll
close by showing you this picture oh
that's a good end the four of us took
together you took a selfie while hugging
at the airport hey can you take a
picture of my family hugging
well we had we just we just we hugged
and then uh that's nice and then I and I
got a little picture yeah yeah a little
three y'all boys look dirty y'all need a
shower that was just what I'm that's
just what I'm observing what people what
do people do before showers they got
into the nearest bathroom dude baths
uh I think tubs I think a body of what I
like the salt on my skin I like what it
does to me it dries it out a little bit
you know when in doubt is clean sorry
break the jet ski out
I'm glad you made it back
it's wonderful to be together again on
this podcast I got a wreck for you a
wreck baby wreck baby one two three four
you know what the I'm just gonna wreck
the latest the last tick tock I watched
before we before we did this this is I
don't follow this person okay but this
video comes up from the daily Victorian
she said there are five things first of
all the daily Victorian she's doing yoga
they didn't do that while she's doing
yoga she's telling you five things to
make you cool
in conversation but it was basically
like tips to be more socially aware
in group settings where conversations
are happening like conversational
techniques oh cool
um the description says for my fellow
mirror balls I do not know who mirror
balls are I don't think I'm one of them
but maybe I am now that's a Taylor Swift
thing right
no I think it's a maybe it's a yoga
person thing
I have no idea okay Jenna also has no
idea which makes you feel better
so the daily Victorian told me that you
can be the you were saying person if
you're in a if you're in a group setting
and then there's like somebody's telling
a story and then there's it gets
sidetracked and other people start
talking you can be the cool person who's
like
um
Jasmine you were saying
and then let them get so you're the
person who like if somebody's telling a
story and it gets sidetracked sometimes
it never gets back so being that person
who's sensitive you're you know and I'm
always looking for ways to improve my
social acuity
so for me
um I'm gonna try to be the you were
saying person
I could also be the stay with me person
which if somebody is telling a story and
then people start dropping off you can
be the person who's who stays with them
I'm with you
finish your story yep that's good yeah
those good that's good advice
yep there's also the to be fair person
if somebody if a group of people are
talking about somebody who's not present
and they're saying something that's not
necessarily gossip but like maybe it's
um
the critique is founded but it's still
nice to be the to be fair person where
you're you
she said no one likes to be called out
on being mean or a gossip but like if
you can turn something into like to be
fair
I mean to be fair you got this all from
a tick tock
it's a little bit valid
solid credit
but you see it turning into a little bit
of a dog piling situation to be the to
be fair person all you have to do is
interject and say to be fair and then
give just a little bit more of a
balanced take on the situation
that's it that's it this is what I'm
recommending I haven't even gotten
through all five of them
thank you the daily Victorian well how
is that Victorian
how's yoga Victorian don't worry about
it I mean you know I don't want to
dictate what somebody's doing I don't
know anything about this but I thought
I'd be getting tips on like stockings
and you know not taking baths putting
fruit up to my nose so I can walk into a
room and I smell everybody you know
Victoria and stuff you do need those
things turrets you were saying spindly
things I love a Victorian home I love
the Victorian I'm with you you know what
I would absolutely love if you would
adopt those oh come on those things
no cheap shots no no I'm saying if you
were to say to be fair if you were to
say I'm with you you're fair you were
saying that would be that'd be pretty
awesome you were saying
[Music]
biscuits what will you be saying
let us know what you think about this
episode also please leave us voicemails
with your candid reactions 1-88
earpod one
hey Rhett and Link this is uh Tegan I'm
20 years old and I've been a long time
Watcher and listener of the podcast ever
since like 2014 or whatever it started
um I just wanted to call in because I
heard what Rhett was talking about about
how the podcast has been good at
maintaining a friendship between you two
and recently I started a podcast with my
brother
and he goes to a different college and
it's been really nice to connect and I
totally relate to what Rhett was talking
about and it's been really nice
but I just want to thank you guys for
inspiring me to do the podcast in
general love what you do bye
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
foreign
[Music]